you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is game 4 of
4 from the match between the car knock
mirror in the world's top chess engine
stop fish and this one as you can see
stock fish is without the beep on knock
c'mere is playing on his own in this one
with the white pieces and again for the
most part I'll simply be showing the
moves to the game so game once again
just like in game 3
where stock fish was without the age
pawn now Chimaera starts with E for
Bishop d7 9c3 a3
I guess just preventing any ideas of a
pin against the night trying to get into
an ideal upon center c5 is there to
interfere with that idea Knight f3
Knight f6 reinforcing e4 Bishop e7
preparing now to fianchetto black now
strikes right at the moment where this
rook is vulnerable pawn takes Knight
takes Knight takes Queen takes white is
there in time to defend the knight white
castles Knight d4 91 LightSquared bishop
skit off the board soon in this one
notice how you have to be very careful
maybe already at this point here if
you're taking the bishop queen takes
this can maybe be a bit annoying to kick
the night you know if you're trying to
do this there's Knight to b3 maybe
you're going to be weakened on the light
squares so instead first doing something
about the knight remedial e with c3
light square bishop scum off now the
knight has to react Queen e2 preparing
to lend some more support to d1 if
needed if there's more pressure on that
square with a rook placing itself to d8
knights come off which i think is a
welcome sight click on F to D one more
exchange is the better since white as
that pawn Plus still
and I guess at this point preparing some
break with d4 but notice at this point
d4 can maybe always be met with c4 and
then it's the B to pawn that could be
targeted since it's not so easily moved
black would be clamping down on that
square if there's a pun on the c4 square
so rook c2 eventually we have the white
Queens come off the board so I think
another welcome sight as more pieces are
exchanged now the White King gets
working so that there's a bit of a
change of the guard here with the White
King around to defend let's say the d3
pawn or the beep on which will allow the
white rooks to do something a bit more
active so after a 5 white does not want
black to clamp down with a 4 so a 4 by
Nakamura d5 and what do we have just
then we had g5 and g4 so another another
fixed pun on a dark square a welcome
sight I believe on the white side in an
ideal world if we look at what pieces
would you like to exchange in such a
position if white can exchange both sets
of rooks this will be I think much
simpler to play and I think there would
be a very clear plan of the King getting
to c4 and maybe even b5 or shifting over
in the d5 square targeting any one of
these four black pawns meanwhile there's
not going to be on the white side any
fixed pawns for this dark square Bishop
to target okay so King G 6 H 3 F 3 the
only thing that white does not have in
this position is space we look at all
these pawns here a lot of pawns on the
fifth rank and the corresponding 4th
rank there's only a couple so there's a
slight space advantage when we look at
good and bad bishops it's of course
black who has the bad bishop
but these rooks are going to be more
active clearly right the Brooks could
get on a half-open file on the black
side whereas white is still strictly
defensive but White's still up the pun
okay so after h5 bishop f2 keeping
pressure on b2 and eventually there is
going to be some progress made notice
after this h4 move this is an
interesting point because now h3 is
potentially at some point going to be a
target to a black rook so another
another reason why is why you would
really like to get the the rooks off the
board at this moment here is because if
the position does open up and it's going
to have to open up in some way if white
is going to try to win if the position
does open up you always have to be
concerned about a black rook potentially
targeting h3 and if he falls well he's
just a few steps away from queening it's
very fast so it's a long-term idea with
this h4 move if you're going to play
this as black you want to make sure you
keep a rook around so that he remains a
potential target
okay so Bishop II one you have to defend
b2 King eventually gets to this a2
square slow and steady at this point
right here black can really do nothing
if white wants a draw you can get a draw
just by going back and forth this rook
is perfect on this square e for keeping
control of the fourth-ranked squares you
go back and forth on these two if you
really wanted to and just make sure you
watch over your base point B to the only
point where there's some pressure
okay so I'll rip d7 rook c4 where is
this next break going to happen d4 it is
by move 52 we finally have some action
and the position opens up now come you
are just under 20 minutes these are just
to give you some indication of the time
spent on each of these moves so Bishop
takes pawn is pinned to the King rook d7
Bishop back
and now we have finally the white rook
getting active but without the black
with this D file I should say now open
the black rook is now very active this
Bishop can't move so easily drop f3 and
then h3 soon enough so you have to
defend rook e1 King d7 this King the
White King has to go in a different
direction I was thinking the white King
would maybe want to go over on this side
of the board to challenge the rip what
would maybe have been wrong with King to
b1 at this point there is rook d1 check
and the rook is getting over here so
that's probably not a good idea to make
use of the b1 square so rook c5 instead
rook b6 eventually the C pawn gets
rolling he set into action right now set
into motion King d7 rookie a he's there
defended by the bishop wants to stay
active notice if we do a quick
comparison who has the more active rooks
of course the white rook white of course
does not want to exchange it so easily
white again could if we wanted to have a
draw I believe just kind of going back
and forth with the rook keeping
defensive the bishop having the bishop
keep defensive the pawn I don't believe
that would there would really be a way
for black to make progress maybe black
would I'm not sure what exactly black
would do to make progress still being
down upon I think they would be fine
with going back and forth a little bit
but something bad ends up happening
there's a slight slip up here Bishop c5
the evaluation is roughly equal but it
starts to shift around this point here
in fact after rook to b7 this was an
interesting moment because it's reading
you can't see it in the video right now
but it's reading approximately minus 1
where black is saying it that black is
better after this rook to b7 move it's
saying that black is better what was
being suggested here is to play
strictly defensive move but after b7 it
suggests rook takes f3 but that move
wasn't playtime to be perfectly honest I
don't know why I don't have an answer to
that I'm not sure why rook takes f3 was
not played here and instead of bit
instead of this Bishop to d8 move I
don't know
but following up we have Bishop a3
Bishop is just going back and forth
route to b3 Bishop c5 this pawn is going
to be one now after rook to d4 that you
can't defend that a for pawn so that
pawn is finally won back after 74 moves
keeping my Nakamura is under five
minutes so it's very easy to go wrong
it's very easy to go wrong it's computer
if you have a lot of time but now
there's very little very little time
look c4 to defend can't really I mean
this pawn is past but easy just can't go
anywhere this Bishop is keeping a close
eye over them so the rooks come off b3
and eventually what we have is an
imbalance where white gets the bishop
but black it's a ton of pawns in fact
just a few more moves where we have four
passed pawns this is not going to turn
out well for team white not enough you
have the king and the rook that can help
these pawns get rolling and that's
exactly what happens
black first making life a little bit
more difficult for this pawn to even
think about getting to the fifth rank
King b5 another check King a for the
Bishop backs up g4 if you try to run
right away he's going to get right
behind and well maybe this is still even
winning but the main point here is that
just get him working with the main
threat of if Bishop takes pawn now you
could push and made a move like rook
here with rook to h3 and this pawn will
promote soon enough
so it's g4 unmov'd 92 rook h7 rook f3
King tries to get over in time but these
pawns are just too much they get pushing
and after King to d5 not come you're
ahead enough and simply threw in the
towel there's not going to be a way to
stop these pawns as an example if Bishop
to a5 there's f4 rook h4 there's rook a
three ideas of rook a to check rook
takes pawn
well you're attacking the bishop I mean
what more can you do
rook here if the bishop let's say goes
to b6 to watch over one of the promotion
squares there's h2 you can't take them
because of a check and well what else
are you going to do
Bishop here these pawns are just too
much they keep moving and one of them is
going to promote and however you slice
it white is going to lose so a very
interesting game again feel free to
share with a very interesting match
starting out in Games one and two having
computer assistance and games three and
four with pawn odds so feel free to
share any feedback you have on this or
what maybe might make any and even more
interesting match than the one we just
saw here between Nakamura and stockfish
so that's all for now hope you enjoyed
all four games and at the end of this
video I'll provide a link to a playlist
where you can view all four games that's
all for now hope you enjoyed it take
care bye
you